[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is our you garbage it's the
show where we sit down with your
favorite comedians and find it if they
grew up classy or if their [ __ ] trash
and that's the bottom line
I'm your host page Foley coming at you
on a beautiful day here in a story of
Queens my co-host is coming at you from
an undisclosed location somewhere on the
southern tip of the great state of New
Jersey is a Garden State kid give it up
for Kevin James Ryan everybody hey gang
happy to be here am I in Wildwood am I
in New York who knows I'm ping pong and
back and forth under the nightfall if
you know what I mean
one toke over the line Oh buddy I'm
wherever you don't need me that's where
I'm at
okay one second you blink I'm back in
Washington Heights next time I'm on the
nor'easter down here on Maurice beer if
I could smokey in the bald man breaker
breaker one-niner got the Bandit on the
loose skipping the fat so what's up guys
happy to be here if you haven't already
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes also the full video
is available on youtube so check that
the [ __ ] out very nice you guys we're
gonna kick things off with some fan
submissions here we have we have a vault
locked to the teeth stacked to the brim
with our loyal fan submissions we're
gonna kick things off right here right
now with some of those kippie what do
you got well as you know may or may not
know patreon is up and running and we
get so many submission questions from
you guys that there's no way we would be
able to get to all of them so what we're
doing is if you do join the patreon
right away well answer me and Foley will
do one of your are you garbage questions
so that's where we are at right now
first of all shout out to everybody
that's [ __ ] signed up so far it's I
mean yes'm our first goal was a hundred
patrons uh you know and we're almost
were like 70% there at this point and at
a hundred I'm gonna go me and Foley are
gonna go to his [ __ ] parents house
the [ __ ] dump II grew up in and we're
gonna do an MTV Cribs style garbage
edition on that [ __ ] California
split-level ez got down there I didn't
think we'd get twenty patreon so I gotta
[ __ ] talk to my mom about this now I
gotta get this brought a Walmart gift
card or I'll tell her Cole's open back
up you were a couple of Kohl's cash you
know what it means if this brought us
some lunch reservation at cc's I'll
throw some chicken nuggets in the
backyard for your dad and lock the door
yeah it's gonna be fun man patreon the
Pole patreon thing is fun so please come
on come on onboard and join us and if
not that's okay too that I got to cut
the pot every week at the time we
appreciate everybody exactly nothing
changes but we do have three different
levels of patreon there's trash there's
a garbaggio which is a little bit class
er glass here and then the highest level
is filthy animals so check that out all
right [ __ ] into it enough human a here
yeah enough for that let's go
boo let's go ball B hit me what do you
got
this one's from Mac Cuddy have you ever
drank Serge soda it's like the one of
those like [ __ ] extra caffeinated
we did with jolt we did well listen
here's my thing you're a young you're a
young whippersnapper I remember when
jolt came out in the early 88 in a line
at the 7-eleven I think you have a pair
of Jordans kind of for Christmas that
year no we weren't allowed to that that
might as well have been crack cocaine in
my house
sure of course which very bitter
fighting over it that means my mom stole
my stash we weren't a la I thought I
thought it would kill you that's how
that's weird yeah well I remember so
there was us nobody sold
the jolt was the only one we knew about
and shout out to parents deli they were
the only one that sold it like no League
name-brand like wah-wah didn't sell a
[ __ ] none of the gas stations sold it
he couldn't get it at the supermarket
you have the I guess this [ __ ] piranha
had a hookup he also had the only Boar's
Head ain't only Boar's Head lunch
meeting town so we used to go all the
time we used to ride our bikes there and
[ __ ] him we couldn't tell your parents
you were gettin [ __ ] jolt soda at the
same amount of Evan - - 20 ounce bottle
had like it was a weapons of like 17
cups of [ __ ] coffee that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] no joke you were dude you would
take a sip and you would feel your teeth
starting to rot out of your [ __ ] head
yeah we were I got give him I give him
credit oh man talk about [ __ ] genius
marketing in Jesus genius graphic design
that lightning bolt through the Oh Oh
put that on a t-shirt and sell it hello
alright next one comes from Christian
aka Chrissy Haysbert calafate that's I
believe that's from the history guy he
knows people shout out to you guys have
you alright this is a [ __ ] this is
have you ever taken tools from around
your house to build a fort in the woods
and like scavenging for pieces of wood
with your friends dude I there was this
girl that lived next door to me when I
when we lived in wilkes-barre ok whoo
down from the mountains into the big
city whoa down from the mountains yeah
a bunch of Clampetts and this chick I
guess she basically molested me I don't
know I didn't see it that way I was 10
she was 13 I'm playin doctor in the
woods oh my god it was it was insane I
look back on it now because I didn't
know what to do but if like I just knew
where to put my like to take my weenie
and put it in her whoo-hoo-hoo had a
pretty fun time how did you get to this
part from building the fort in the woods
with your friends have you ever built a
fort I'm gonna [ __ ] opens up the fat
shell just bragging about getting laid
as a dis as a 10 year old no so what we
did was is that we purposely we're gonna
build a
or in the woods where we could go and
and and do these things and hook up and
all that kind of stuff so we scoured for
wood if I can took tools from mining I
knew where there was some and you're a
little [ __ ] and your little underoos
power ranger tighty whities I don't know
I got a 1x3 sticking out of my sweats
it's you know you had a troubled
childhood when you when you when you got
a little stinger an agenda to things in
your underwear that's a bad look if you
got a combo if your moms do it washing
your underwear any and your getting laid
there's something wrong with your
childhood you guys were [ __ ]
backwoods country folk ah man it was
weird she was 13 I was 10 but yeah we
[ __ ] took tools went and got wood and
like looking back on it the construction
design was it was it was really it
wasn't up to code I'll tell you that
much
he stuck though we stuck the wood like
halfway into the mud like into the end
of the ground paint and then built
around there nothing
way into the mud ain't nothing come on
[ __ ] too quick for you today I'm
throwing eat what about you that's all
we did that's all I mean who do we grew
up in like there was it was the suburbs
and there was just wood so we and
everybody they were building
construction there was new construction
everywhere of like those McMansion
houses
olden old brothers so we would go just
[ __ ] steal from the jobsites woods
two-by-fours plywood whatever and just I
mean I must have built 50 [ __ ] forts
as a kid in different woods I mean and
then as you got older you know you stole
a little PVC maybe made like a
three-foot long or whatever you know
real classy start putting the wiring in
the fort
I got a ceiling fan a window unit I tell
you what those woods wherever they were
wherever you grew up those woods it was
a real love and hate and joy and fear
relationship involved because you would
just be in the would you be like oh this
is awesome
soon started getting dark out you're
like let's get the [ __ ] out of here all
brands it was also you ever be in the
woods have you ever been in the woods
and you just come across like an
abandoned house
just in the middle of the woods or like
you come across like what used to be
like a fireplace and you're like what
the [ __ ] there was always like some like
weird graffiti that's where the older
kids went you knew there was some kind
of satanic ritual going on out there in
the middle of night [ __ ] frightening
but if you're looking to [ __ ] make
out what a 13 year old that was that was
the spot to take her Jesus Christ
yeah man spent all of my childhood in
the woods and dude one time I found like
a [ __ ] they found like a three-foot
graves the size of a casket with the
shuffle like we like interrupted the
digging of it what yeah was the person
still there no it was just like like the
size of a casket what was that like six
you know seven feet whatever by like
three feet yours would be you know five
foot by six foot you're a little a
little more portly gentleman and then
yeah it was just dug like three feet
deep and there was like the big mound of
dirt and the [ __ ] shovel was just in
the sand left the shovel there yeah this
is from Steve Brady growing up did your
family have assigned seats in the
kitchen table as a kid that was like
that was like your real estate you
didn't have you didn't own anything as a
kid especially a little piece of garbage
kid you know what I mean that was like
that was the only thing you could you
could plant your flag on was that
whatever seat where it's a table yeah I
know there's one place you couldn't sit
at the Foley house that's in the [ __ ]
big dogs chair oh yeah
unless you were paying the check it was
funny cuz every time we went out to
dinner it would always be like a replica
of at home you know what I mean your dad
my dad was never at your mom my dad was
never a booth guy it was one of the
table never a booth really yeah that's
right table guys trashy you need a booth
dude you love a good booth at a diner
you like a booth I know that I know
about you you like to have a booth in a
[ __ ] omelet I know Kippy get the
burger one kid begets a burger I'll call
Hank though he's getting
coleslaw and pickle skip you don't touch
it yeah all right this is from Steven
Picaro have you ever have you ever
watched the price The Price is Right in
a bar I can't say I have if you if
you're at the bar for the 11 a.m. kick
off of the price is right that's [ __ ]
bad news dude you got bigger issues than
what's on TV okay if you're doing if
you're [ __ ] half three sheets to the
wind when those [ __ ] showcase
showdown comes on only if I was working
at a bar that's the only time that that
would be on yeah all right this is from
Jason Donaldson this is a [ __ ]
homerun I'm sure someone in your family
has you guys you're [ __ ] derelict
this is from Jason has anyone in your
family ever worn a suit jacket with
sweat pants to a fancy family event I
don't know you your sweat you were
[ __ ] joggers to a funeral not too
long ago there they were made in a khaki
pants not now but there's elastic in
them at the end was yeah that's not a
good look if you can see your socks at a
funeral you [ __ ] no socks at a funeral
is just disrespectful
for a while my dad had a pair of cargo
sweatpants oh that he would push the
boundaries of fact where he couldn't
couldn't wear he couldn't yeah there was
definitely a sweater tucked into those
at one point with maybe a sport coat
over it it goes somewhere
yeah you know I remember one time I had
a wedding to go to and like I was like a
little fat kid and I guess the sopranos
was not that it was in the middle with
subtractors and my dad we took about
like a family we had to go like a family
wedding their cousins a wedding here son
maybe that's all tragedy that side of
the family was and I he got me a like a
half turtleneck you know what I mean
like a sweater turtleneck type thing and
I just and I just wore a the suit over
that I didn't have a shirt and tie I
just I'd like to Tony Soprano spesh you
know what I mean like a real [ __ ]
Guido [ __ ] yeah what are you a [ __ ]
pit boss at [ __ ]
like changing 500 hey Merle is going on
her break
yeah it's wow that's funny [ __ ] alright
this is from Deadeye Davey anyone in
your family ever have to wear an
eyepatch
oh I tell you that Deadeye Dave man that
kid hits a lot of [ __ ] homeruns damn
that's a [ __ ] good piece of business
I did I had a word on multiple occasions
for what because I wear contacts that I
was shitty about them when I was younger
so I would always scratch my cornea so
you go in they give you the drops they
put ointment in your ID let me put a
[ __ ] eye patch on you for a week or
two happened like three or four times I
know I wonder what my buddies house one
time any answers I didn't know this
wouldn't had to go like not for people
you know what I mean I went to knock for
I went to knock for my boy and he opened
up in an eyepatch on us you know [ __ ]
plane crash I assume you'll be staying
for dinner than Kippy okay this is from
Zach Buckman Buckman that's a good
attitude that's a good [ __ ] baseball
name out there bat Zach Bachman girls
day doc Buckman buck Buckman was
something I think that was Seinfeld I
don't think so um okay do you have it
have you or a family member and ever
ended up with a bald head because
someone forgot to put the attachment on
the back when you were getting it like
an at-home haircut like did you ever
[ __ ] up your haircut so bad that you had
to shave it no because we didn't if my
mom gave us a homemade haircut we were
kids she wasn't using [ __ ] Clippers
she was using scissors got the bowl out
the good pasta bowl and [ __ ] head you
up real nice
yeah that's how wack my [ __ ] was never
had clippers I mean my mom was doing me
and I brought like would they could
doing her hair on the back deck and like
say you're like sitting like one of
those ready glue coolers or whatever and
she's trying to get she's trying to like
fade up my brother and she [ __ ] his
[ __ ] up man and that she had the [ __ ]
she had to take it all off like but to
like a zero dude what if he
like a [ __ ] he look like you a chemo
patient it was people were like looking
like what the [ __ ] wrong with that kid
plus you had big ears it was a bad look
that's imagine you tagging along behind
them eating dirt s they only feed one of
those kids huh yeah all right let's see
we got two more I think all right this
is from Kyle Noel no I don't think this
isn't this is a no for me as your family
ever gone to a food bank but still had
money for smokes and booze I want to say
yes and in a way I remember my mom you
my mom used food stamps back in the
early 80s to mail letters huh I'm a
letters don't bro and she was smoking so
she was up to something I'll tell you
that yeah I mean if she's catching
Bernie's and yeah we never did
I mean my money was never that tight but
I never won that one time when I first
started doing comedy I was you know I
didn't have a job was [ __ ] dead broke
and I was walking past like you know the
food bank fill abundance or whatever and
they were giving out some [ __ ] fresh
[ __ ] bags and groceries and I was
thinking about hopping in line for sure
I was like I can't do it let me get to
let me get to all right and I think this
is the last one for today hitter from
Jeffrey Jeffrey Manzi as a kid did your
parents make you stop at the gas station
to pick out candy and slightly cheaper
prices before going to the movies what
[ __ ] do that now what do you of
course my whole life you did that as a
kid yeah that's trash dude that's try no
matter how tight money was my mama baked
I'm not going to the [ __ ] movies if
I'm not getting the bag of P corn you
know what I mean classy old broad huh
dad dude that's something I know the
first time whatever my buddy Liam's
house like oh we're going to the movies
and we stopped at the [ __ ] deli and
everybody started putting like Twizzlers
dr. Davidson yeah what the [ __ ] are we
doing I got a dub on me let's hit the
candy bar son I
some nerds rope with my name on it not
[ __ ] buying these bootleg sx the
candy at the movie theater is usually
pretty wack most yeah I'll give it to
you I'm not a big sweet sky but I would
do it I would get the [ __ ] pretzel
nuggets with the super pretzel nuggets
with the hot cheese if you can't put a
Kim put those down your pants and sneak
that we would bring we bring soft
pretzels we were just doing a box you
guys once the dogs will be ready in a
minute you're looking for an outlet
please I can put this toaster oven real
quick you guys got a freezer back there
I got some snakes in there that's it
guys thanks so much for writing in yes
thank you
you guys are [ __ ] consistently
hitting home runs we got the back and
funniest listeners that's so great but
yeah guys shout out if you my right when
you join the patreon we will read your
questions on an episode so as we
appreciate all support thanks so much
let's go baby
folks we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly special guest here
with today his acting credits include
HBO's bored to death FX is Louie inside
Amy Schumer and of course better call
Saul his writing credits the Pete Home
Show in wet hot American summer and of
course he has appeared on the Joe Rogan
experience on the bonfire Last Call with
Carson Daly Chelsea Lately he has his
own Comedy Central Presents he has his
own half-hour Comedy Central Presents
and of course he has his own special you
let me down ladies and gentlemen just a
small-town kid made good but the big
question on everybody's mind today is he
garbage give it the [ __ ] up from mr. Joe
DeRosa thank you so nice this intro so
we go for every time buddy good to see
you thank you for doing the show your
first question I want to ask you this
real quick is do you think you're
garbage yeah yeah I could save us a lot
of time
for the listener Joe Kevin and I all
grew up very similar background Joe
actually grew up I think like a couple
towns over from me I went the ballistic
in high school you went to the Catholic
school I went to camera Bishop Kenrick
number one right there yeah
became Kennedy kenric and then it closed
when your schools combined man that's
that's not a good look
yeah it sucks yeah we we showed pictures
of it on the bonfire recently and it's
just the saddest building I mean it's if
there's nothing in it now
but just the sight of it and there was
just it was it's just this big brown
square and it had no amenities that had
nothing and then I think three or four
years after I graduated
they built like a state-of-the-art great
beautiful high school five minutes from
where I grew up and I would I would be
on a 90 minute bus ride every morning to
get to kenric oh that is such a shitty
move man when either your school is
under construction while you're going
there or when you graduate they [ __ ]
hooking up again we got a pool now like
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah it's it's it's a
yeah I really missed out on that one but
oh wait did they send a ball that was
always a weird thing especially in the
suburbs if you went to the private
school instead of the public school they
would have to send their like own bus to
go get you and you would steal it you'd
always see the Catholic school kids
waiting at like 5:30 in the morning to
get picked up at the bus stop and agree
pulls up the yellow bus dock yeah yeah
regular what yeah yeah yellow bus yeah
it was weird it was just my bus I think
had a total of ten kids don't please so
weird because I went to public school I
went to I'm not too far away I went to
Council Rock so it was all just [ __ ]
anybody anytime the kids would go to
like wood or like Ryan or any of those
schools there would be like three kids
on a bus that holds 55 people just
[ __ ] strange bunch of my buddies went
to council Rock oh yeah yeah what time
did you grow up in because I I figured
you grew up right around where Kendrick
was and the suburbs of Philly what town
did you actually grow up it sort of I
mean I grew up
I was born in Philly Northeast and I
grew up in Collegeville which is more
referred to as trapped now yeah but I
grew up there and when the name of your
town changes it was always there was
part of it known as tre it wasn't that a
change to be fair it was it's just I
don't know maybe it's not more no I
don't [ __ ] know it's a weird a lot of
weird it's a lot of other places I'm
sorry a lot of places are big on that
man Philly's big on that too they'll
change the name of the neighborhood to
try to make it sound a lot better than
it was yeah well trap is not a great
name that's only referred to drug houses
I always thought College was kind it's
nice what's the well it's like single
family home yeah yeah when I grew up
there was a little more sort of stranger
things vibe 80 suburbia a lot more
farmland and woods and and that sort of
thing but still something you know still
some development in houses and stuff to
ride your bike to as a kid now it's very
very developed and ritzy is not the term
but you know it's these big to make
mansion type things yeah yeah exactly
that's everywhere there now it's a very
different looking than when I grew up
there
which is a shame because I feel like a
lot of kids you know I think the best
environment to live in if you're able to
is to get that sort of city suburbs
thing where you're in the suburbs at
night so it's quiet and then you can
kind of take a short ride into some
activity area and stuff like that and I
don't think a lot of kids get to
experience that anymore I feel like
you're either out in the middle of
nowhere
or you're just in you know over
developed land you know I feel like
people don't get to experience what I
experienced growing up which was you you
could go this way a few minutes and be
in farmland or go that way a few minutes
and be in the center of town or you know
go that way was a trailer park and
'we was a little bit of a nicer suburb
or yeah you know you got to get a taste
of it all you know yeah
sorry there's a recurring theme that
anytime there's just one trail if you
grew if there's a lot of trailer parks
it's fine but anytime there's one
trailer park in a neighborhood that's
always a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I know
what you mean it's the owner wouldn't
sell to the developer [ __ ] you wine
selling yeah yeah people would you guys
would you and your buddies hop on the
train and go into the city by yourselves
as as kids no no we we would drive in
once once people you know once some of
us got licenses and stuff but now we
never trained in the train was I mean
because the train was all the way over
in Norrish town you know or towns that
were just as far so it didn't make any
sense by the time you got over there you
might as well drive the extra 20 minutes
and do you guys drive down there and get
weed in high school we did that all the
time in college we did I didn't smoke
weed till college so I didn't drink till
college either so we went in college we
were drive down to to Philly to get weed
did you have a place to go or you just
like drive to a bad neighborhood and
like ask for somebody we eventually had
connections but I definitely did the
thing where we drove and just started
asking people and then you know you get
robbed and wait here we'll be right back
give me that I need the money now though
I need the money yeah yeah yeah I had a
guy tell me wants to go wait in the
bushes for him [ __ ] brutal we used to
cross the Delaware River to go buy booze
in Jersey because they were like because
the PA is their state store you know to
get booze you have to go to a state
store so yeah we'd go to Jersey to like
you know something like [ __ ] Rocky's
Liquor Mart type thing mm-hmm
like outside of Camden or whatever and
we pulled up the one time and he's like
four thugs just came to the car and they
were like so like can you buy US beer
and they're like yeah sure let me just
crack the window and it was like a
vending machine it was like an ATM
machine they just have taken out money
just and just walked away I just took it
through the crack in the window and left
yeah I think that was that was like a
common
thing like if these suburban kids are
first of all you know you get older you
realize how insulting it is to like
drive into a rough neighborhood and ask
for a favor you know of any kind can you
can you make our lives even more easier
please yeah yeah so I got it and years
later I understood why that man took my
money from me you know I loved it and
growing up did you have any brothers or
sisters or was it just you just me I'm
adopted I'm the only child did you know
you were adopted when you were a kid or
is that something they told you later on
yeah no I knew my whole I don't remember
them telling me I always knew just oh
okay yeah yeah I always knew but I am
Egyptian my mom didn't tell me that
until I was about 12 okay and their
backgrounds Italian yeah
oh yes and she didn't know how I would
handle it she didn't know you know as I
say it's still pretty cool that they
told you off the jump or like that you
always knew because I always think it's
a it's a weird thing when like they tell
you like as you're an adult like you
know your sister is actually your mom or
something like you know Irish Catholic
[ __ ] like that I don't understand
that yeah you know I mean I guess I
guess there's some interest in you know
you don't want the kid to be hurt or
feel different or something like that
but I mean my god like it's so much
harder to do it later you might as well
just yeah I know yeah if they give all
these traits of your family and you're
like wait I mean [ __ ] it though yeah
yeah make it normal don't make it the
new normal just make it normal from the
B so you thought you were Italian up
until you were 12 yeah so that was a
little bit strange but I wasn't when my
mom told me I wasn't upset you know I
was actually kind of excited because it
was sort of this exotic other yeah
something different different yeah yeah
are your parents like hardcore Italian
what does that mean right - they're
decals on their windows do you guys get
a white Christmas do you guys get a
white plastic Christmas tree is what I'm
asking Joe we did when I was little we
of course you did yeah every Italian in
the Northeast as a way
like Christmas tree those things when as
soon as I have enough space to have a
[ __ ] Christmas tree I'm gonna get one
of those I think those are awesome but
ya know we yeah they're I mean they're
you know I was pretty traditional
you know East Coast Italian yeah would
your dad do growing up he worked in
computers he actually worked at Sperry
UNIVAC which became unisys but that's
spare Univ X the company invented the
first computer ever generally ever so my
dad worked there and my mom did she was
a secretary stuff like that I like the
Christmas stuff did you guys have
colored lights on the house at Christmas
did you go white colored lights
my mom eventually twent
they still decorate the house they win
sometimes in their their community like
they win the awards sometimes for like
really they go all out like that
yeah but it's very tastefully done
casually it's not like Griswold style
but like you know but they do
yeah they decorate there's a fine line
between gaudy and tasteful when it comes
to when it comes to Christmas especially
in aliens on Christmas it's it can get
dicey and I got the classy vibe I got
the classy vibe from when you said your
mom went from colored and then she
transitioned into into white lights I
think that was like around the 90s I was
I got this [ __ ] color glaze and
trashy [ __ ] we gotta get away from this
well I made it's funny she really likes
this but I made her cuz I go there every
year for Christmas her Christmas tree
two years ago she was trying to make it
like all pastel colors and we started
the day I always helped him set up the
tree so the day we were setting up the
tree she started pulling out the stuff
she bought and I was like we're not
using that when I use in that we're
doing a Christmas tree and I went with
my dad to Walmart and bought like
traditional you know like read your
stuff yeah yeah and I came back and we
did it that way like classic and she
loves it she was like I loved she'd she
wants to do it that way all the time
again now and that's that old-school
[ __ ] is the best man if I had a house I
would
I would do the color lights I would do
the plastic Santa Claus I would do all
that fun [ __ ] man let that feels like
it's that's fun it's a holiday this [ __ ]
where it's all like white lights and
like paper angels and [ __ ] like that and
did you guys do tinsel on the tree yeah
we still do Garland we don't do tinsel
cuz the dogs
Garland's nice look on the classy touch
tinsel is [ __ ] my step my dad my
pears got divorced my dad started too
intense I was like what the [ __ ] you did
I forgot about that
dogs yeah the dogs eat pencil then it's
hanging out of their ass yeah yeah it's
bad yeah the garbage stuff is the best
we used to put trains around our
Christmas tree yes life forms and Lionel
trains going around that's awesome
that's awesome I loved I love [ __ ] like
that man I mean it's you can't you know
that's fun it's like Halloween I love
like classic Halloween you know they go
all out to Halloween you know not really
my dad did with the costumes but
decorating the house not I don't think
so I don't remember it being all decked
up but my dad was really we'd really get
into my costume so he would make he
would help me craft the other parents
always loved my costumes because my dad
would really help me like craft like a
costume you know so before you like I
was Freddie one year Freddie Krueger and
he made me the glove cuz it was before
you could buy them for kids so he
actually made me a glove that's correct
I lost a bit of [ __ ] hit the
cafeteria that day I'll pay that yeah
he's my dad would buy me one of those
rubber mats that you had to like look
through the nose hole and keep it moving
yeah since what does Captain America
wear jeans I thought it was awesome but
it's garbage but I always thought it was
awesome that one house where that where
the parents would go so far out that
they would like they would like try to
scare you like the dad would be dressed
up as like a scarecrow sitting on a
[ __ ] lawn
in the front lawn yes when I think he
does a god that's awesome but then
looking back I'm like [ __ ] was that guy
doing
that's good I mean you know those days
are gone I mean you could never yeah you
can't you can't dress up anymore
there's no fun anymore
I mean it's like it's crazy but like I
I'm just thinking of this now but I feel
like that's why there are so many people
in there you know I'm in my 40s now I
still live like I'm in my 20s probably
about on paper you know like I still
want to live in neighborhoods that have
fun bars yeah I don't want to hang out
with 20 people you know I don't want to
hang out with bars with to a bunch of 20
year olds but like I go to I still like
bars where people my age or a little
younger a little whatever like hang out
and drink cheap beer and do shots and
and I like to stay out late and I like
to play video games and I like to do all
this [ __ ] that I think you know in the
traditional sense is is is in quotes
immature but I think that you're seeing
more and more people do that kind of
stuff now you know people that are
marching towards 50 that aren't living
traditional lives for that age bracket
because of this like because it's like
that's the only fun you can have now is
with other people your age that also get
it it's like it's like that fun dad [ __ ]
is done like yeah there's too much
liability with it now there's too much
you know what do you want somebody
else's kids in your house and then you
try to play a prank on the kids and then
one of the kids gets upset or whatever
and then they tell their parents and
then you're blackballed from the [ __ ]
School District or whatever the [ __ ]
it's like who the [ __ ] that way I feel
like the big kid thing is like for
people that don't have kids anymore are
you sure I would have kids and he would
keep being a kid with the kids and it's
like now it's like it's just like now
we'll just we just want to have kids and
we'll just keep hanging out
I think that's the generational thing
like our parents our dads our dads look
at that and like what the [ __ ] you're
watching another guy play a video game
like what the [ __ ] is this right and I
think that's just you know from us being
80s and 90s kids even even something
like as simple as that like video games
like you're saying it's like it used to
be my dad would buy me video games and
I'd play what my friends and my dad
would sit and watch us play and and you
know and sometimes he would play and it
was fun when you're kid I wouldn't play
a video game with a kid now if I didn't
you know what I mean if I had a kid and
his friend was like we want because then
I gotta sit there and go is the content
okay sure it's so beyond it used to just
be that's too much blood and guts where
that's too much nudity yeah that was it
it was it was like outside of that it
was like you know nothing's gonna scar
your brain forever now it's like the
languages was the language okay was the
content okay you know where their
political overtones where there are you
know where their gender over - it's a
girl [ __ ] all this man like now I I want
no part of it man
I've been down I was down I've been on
the show the past few weeks with my
family's been there Mike my nieces and
nephews and the whole time I it's just
my my sister and brothers talking about
talking to other parents about things
they were like you know I just got off
the phone with Billy's dad and then you
know we're next weekend we gotta talk we
got to see Jeannie in that and I'm like
my mom the whole goal is a kid was tell
your parents not talk
I would lot like if my mom talked to one
my friends and moms about something I
love you you were in [ __ ] trouble for
something you know I mean you try to
avoid that at all [ __ ] cost you're
looking to grease somebody at 20 to keep
their mouth shut
like yeah if she has I was over here for
dinner last night
yeah I mean it was you know it's like I
remember finding porn at my friend's
house like with me and my friend finding
porn of his dad's at his house and my
mom finding out about that and it was
just like I don't want you to do that
don't do that yeah it wasn't I got a
call
them and tell them that they put my son
in a unsafe environment there's none of
that it was just like don't do that I
don't need to do that that's wrong and
was like all right and either did or
either listener you didn't listen you
know what I mean like and that was it
but III can't even imagine now what with
the the having a key Ashida [ __ ] that oh
my god you would have a mark on you with
the [ __ ] softball game that would
come off is so creepy did he show it to
them is that what did he show it to the
Mumper yeah I mean can you imagine his
comics like other comics kids I think
yeah it's like you know somebody
somebody's kids he's your comedy and
then it's like and then people are
comedians are getting canceled without
the kid factor in there so then you got
to deal with you got to go to the
parent-teacher thing or whatever the
[ __ ] it is at the school and then
they're going did you say this on
television did you say this on your
podcast do you think that's okay does
your son know you talk like that
because my son does and I don't like
that why would you [ __ ] I never even
thought of that because does that happen
it must we're going strictly ladies and
gentlemen gotta pay to get the goods
IIIi don't know any comics that it has
happened to at least that they've told
me I mean I'm assuming I also don't know
many comics with kids to be honest but
but I mean it happens if you watch those
life after porn things those
documentaries on like Netflix whatever
dates that happens them all the time
they say [ __ ] up yeah
Asia career is a big one she like
retired she moved out to the I think
Arizona she would that to something like
sort of desert II kind of place she has
a daughter she's like I had a kid I
didn't want to do this anymore I wanted
to start a new life I wanted to put this
behind me and and you know and with and
that was shame not with like I'm so
mortified by what I did but just very
much like that chapter is closed I'm
raising a kid now and she she's like
yeah they find out and they treat you
differently and
they judge you and what the [ __ ] man
yeah 2020 that's [ __ ] crazy I just
pictured Bobby Kelly getting yelled at
at a parent-teacher conference he sit in
a little basket and yell that it was 20
years ago dude yeah that's funny man all
right let's get into some questions here
a little game called are you garbage
with you Joe just answer the questions
to the best of your ability and as
honest as you possibly can and we're
gonna find out how garbage you in fact
art if you aren't garbage because maybe
you think you're garbage
and you're not really garbage I gotta
tell you when you said the thing about
your mom going from the colored lights
to the white lights that was the real
clay that was a real that was a real
point in my book point towards not
garbage towards not garbage yeah yeah I
think it's the opposite I think it's
garbage so you might be so garbage
you've brought your rods and cones are
all screwed up Joe I think it's trying
to look classy like which is always we
got a garbage if you're trying to do
something that you things like what rich
people do oh yeah that's always tough
yeah yeah you know it was that our
family that I was drinking Crystal Light
we thought that was like a rich person's
drink we started drinking Crystal Light
in the summer felt like Kennedy's
walking around [ __ ] good Township oh
boy all right here we go a couple of the
basics start now what was the name of
your your grocery store growing up
well jazz shop Acme classy middle the
road all right did you have a garage
growing up no no garage was a
single-family home or a townhouse single
family homes single driveway no garage
driveway yeah no garage basketball net
in the driveway no I didn't play sports
okay what bank did your mom go growing
up what was your bank
it doesn't exist anymore I think it was
called Sovereign Bank ah sovereign was
big back in then yeah Chemical Bank it
burned yeah I don't understand how when
you drive through small towns in like
our area the Philadelphia area has a
bunch of them but these like small banks
that you never heard of it's like how
are you like you must be getting crushed
with ATM fees that people who don't have
huge banks it is weird
pay for this yeah it's that it's also
like I don't know how do you have I got
a mom-and-pop Bank it's weird
yeah like Ambler Savings PA in ambler PA
there's an ambush Savings Bank I swear
to god it's the size of a [ __ ] city
block it's brand new and beautiful I'm
like who could possibly have their money
in there Ambler pit well I went to
Temple Ambler for a year I was that was
one of my questions myself
yeah just for one year did you go to
Temple for the rest of the time or was
that it I transferred to Kutztown okay
was my second that was my second school
I loved Kutztown was really fun when I
was there
got a little Plain Jane since then but
that's always because that's just like
those colleges always expect to PA state
colleges cuz it's just like the college
is the town for the most part like
Kutztown is here you removed that
there's not much going on right yeah no
that was well cuts down itself was a
pretty cool artsy little town it's
actually a place to probably pretty
lovely to live in but yeah the college
certainly was you know a moneymaker for
the town but now towns a lot of the town
people didn't like the college kids
because yeah they were loud and yeah you
know oh you guys animals back then yeah
it was fun man it was it was very Animal
House like when I went there was barely
wild like wild a lot of acid a lot of
weed a lot of [ __ ] drinking did you
stay in the house with your buddies
yeah yeah yeah not a house apartment we
had a whole apartment building where we
mean all my friends occupied every
apartment it was [ __ ] that's pretty I
don't feel like that's more risky to do
now they still like that that college
experience now you know if you are
having it you know you got more of a
chance of getting [ __ ] in trouble or
doing something with all the social
media and [ __ ] like that it's what are
you gonna do I mean you know there was a
time where it was like could you imagine
streaking now like I couldn't really
went in the 90 where people streaking in
the 90s coming guys yeah I I graduated
in 2000 I definitely streaked a couple
times and there was not a [ __ ] there
was not a worry in your head of indecent
exposure it was like conditional that's
a [ __ ] sex crime now if you're on the
wrong block yeah there wasn't there was
no putt like because it was so not
sexual is like no it's funny cuz we ran
naked through a thing like that was the
joke but I couldn't [ __ ] do that now
because cuz everything sucks man we go
lucky Joe DeRosa I can see the tension
in your neck I don't know finding out
about something not you guys like you
guys I'm just thinking about everything
I like that stress of them do that when
you were telling that story about the
about the kid I just pictured you as the
dad funny yeah the kid was like you know
having my kids over and stuff like that
yeah yeah yeah if I had kids I wouldn't
just have kids over what do you got
Kippy all right
did you ever dye your hair and have you
ever have frosted tips never had frosted
tips I definitely dyed my hair I
bleached my hair at the end of high
school yeah like like short bleached
blond like back when like you know
when I graduated high school like the
punk punk was coming back into the
mainstream it was like that very you
know hot topic sure at the mall era so I
did that
you ever have a tail I had a mullet when
I was a kid who knows in eighth grade
did your mom used to cut it no but she
promotes she liked it she was yeah
that's crazy
did you try to grow a mustache or have a
mustache in high school in high school
no now you aren't no no have any male
members of your family uncles or cousins
ever have a ponytail it's not a quick no
when we were little when yeah when we
were young like my cousin it was
different but it's not like when we were
kids there was a thing called a rat tail
yeah you would have your hair shaved but
then you would have like a tail coming
out of the back says a chill down my
spine
yeah my cousin had one of those but I
mean we were like kids 11 yeah you know
I mean it was you can't be a 17 year old
with a rat there lots of it yeah
no nobody in the sense that you're
talking now nobody had okay
nobody was like full-on like yeah I mean
sure like yeah just rocking a ponytail
yeah we'd love to get your ears pierced
as a kid when I was 16 no 15 I always
thought those kids were from the wrong
side of the tracks man it shows up the
[ __ ] science class with his ears did
your mom know about it though yeah no
she approved she let me at 15 she said
when I turned 15 but I had to do it in
the summer because we weren't allowed to
have I went to Catholic school so we
weren't allowed to have facial hair or
earrings or anything like that in school
so I had to do it in the summer so it
healed in time that when I went back to
school I could take it out door the day
so you could rock it on the weekends and
at night yeah we're you the kid do it
like
canal like to get on the bus you put it
in like a [ __ ] you father Steve yeah I
don't remember what was it ever was it a
hoop was it a stud what we were you when
I first I when I first got it I my
friend did my left ear it was just a
gold stud or whatever the [ __ ] it was
awful thing but then when I got like
late high school I got the second one
peer so I just did the two hoops go
along with the half half-assed punk move
motif yeah you know is that B Beastie
Boys you know that it was that whole did
you smoke cigs in high school not really
yeah I've never been to an air show
Willa Grove preferably I like that he's
answer the questions yeah I think I went
to one but I didn't want to go I never
gave a [ __ ] about air shows I was always
like I don't care about this have you
ever gone to the Pennsylvania State Fair
probably yeah I mean I've been to plenty
of fairs cars in the parking lot were
always bad yeah yeah excited about those
yeah this is as an adult not as a kid
but as an adult have there ever gone to
Pennsylvania Dutch country or Amish
country on purpose yeah as an adult no
okay not like a Saturday no [ __ ] growing
up did your mom used to serve Crescent
dinner rolls yes they're trashy but my I
[ __ ] love the [ __ ] out of those
things yeah I mean they're pretty good
how do you feel how do you feel about
the three following Philadelphia staples
number one tomato pie excellent number
two
the pork breakfast dish known as
scrapple excellent favorite and finally
how do you feel about the pork roll pork
roll I could take it or leave it but I
oh whoa whoa whoa what pork roll take it
or leave it
oh my gosh Lissa I don't dislike it but
I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not going
out of my way for it yeah pourquoi one's
a distant third the [ __ ] scrap a
little little [ __ ] tomato pie
yes scrapple all day man well Foley eats
all three of them together so it's I've
been like three tomato pies this summer
already shall I add more police yeah I
got to get to
I haven't had tomato pie in a while it's
time to get back in touch with your
Collegeville roots get back through the
introspection in that statement do you
sprinkle parmesan on it cuz that's my
favorite you got it I think right you
don't have to but yeah it's pretty good
and then there was a place I don't
remember whose corporally sure not they
would put pepperoni on it I don't think
that sounds awesome I've never had
change it was it was unreal it's no
[ __ ] joke man no [ __ ] joke yeah I
know what I'm doing this weekend alright
pick one of the following combos or
Jesus uh I do combos over cheez-its
what that's new money stuff right there
that's Jesus never did it for me man oh
no next to Cheetos or Doritos the [ __ ]
out of here Cheetos and Doritos are like
you might as well be drinking Mountain
Dew with those shoes it's a classy
classy snack if your combos over Cheetos
and what buddy you Reese's Pieces or
M&Ms teams so real against the grain guy
over here I like Adam up is down down
his eyes what's going on Rose a wild
card I won't cross the street for
regular M&Ms I won't cross the street
for him and and I do like Reese's Pieces
but they don't have enough chocolate
flavor I like a problem
do you like the snack known as Funyuns
uh take it or leave it I don't care
good go maybe with some on French onion
dip bugles in French onion dip there you
go trash snack for you make the fingers
with them yeah don't make bugles I think
so I had some last night I swear to God
bugles Ranch [ __ ] unbelievable [ __ ] I
haven't even seen them in forever I just
I was talking about him recently
somebody that's the only way I knew that
they still made him I got a guy who hook
you up yeah
Foley you're like the Smithsonian for
snacks where did you get them from I
mean we're in this town along a
safe-deposit box
who who he with I'm with my girlfriend
we came out to Greenport Long Island
bugles out in the Hamptons yeah that's
[ __ ] crazy I sort of got it's a
little convenience store across the
street from the holy [ __ ] that's wild
man I can't believe it all right yeah
tell anybody you lovely flooding the
Jews out here folks just so everybody
knows just cocaine and rich people
nothing you'd be interested to see did
you Joe DeRosa go to any underage dance
clubs as a kid hundred percent shadows
and King of Prussia yeah they always had
terrible names like Beach Street or King
shampoo on rayon shirt and Z cavariccis
oh you had to be young for Z cavariccis
I got my Z's and got my Z eighth grade I
guess holy [ __ ] yeah they were cheap
either were they you know it's funny I
actually was thinking about that
recently like I remember losing a big
deal to get a pair and it was like they
were expensive I bet like in hindsight
they were like $60 yeah yeah
like they're probably the same prices
like Levi's are now like like you know
the equivalent of like buying an $85
pair of pants right now you know but
asking your mom for that when you were a
kid you had in those situations if I
want to make a big purchase like that I
would have to cover some part of it it
would have to be like around mic Union
for my birthday I would have to like oh
you put 40 down and we'll put the rest
and you know all that life learning
right yeah that's so funny
there's a there's a question you might
that you might be able to relate to you
had a communion you're Catholic did you
ever see any of your communion money you
actually get it
yeah I got confirmation money and
communion money I got some of it yeah I
was allowed to take a little bit of it
and do some fun [ __ ] with it you're an
Italian family too you probably did
pretty good you remember what you got
what you pulled in ah no no idea no idea
but I remember getting like I think like
both times I bought a video game or
something the kids that got bar
Mitzvahed they'd [ __ ] pull in like 10
20 grand like oh yeah what are you
[ __ ] getting married yeah no I got
like you know I probably got a few
hundred bucks or something Tony and it
went into an account you know yeah same
with mine I never got the [ __ ]
account number to that yeah I never saw
a [ __ ] dime of that money no no no
I'm going okay we were you guys growing
up were you a cheese whiz household not
not like that there's a big argument
about this with people and I it pisses
me off
people think cheese whiz is the [ __ ] in
the can and it's not cheese whiz is the
sauce but it was called Cheez Whiz it
was in a jar and it was called Cheez
Whiz it's what you get on a cheesesteak
sometime so yeah that yes that jar
there's a great red red top my mom liked
the spray stuff a little bit sometimes
but no we didn't we were you know we
were as an Italian household we were big
on like actual like cheese he's properly
she's in pepperoni and you know super
sought you know you know that kind of
[ __ ] dude cuz I mean we're
Catholic trash' like cheese and
pepperoni that's that was like a craft
single and you know like a PML or
something we didn't [ __ ] with any of
that yeah I'm just getting into because
now my my wife is from Europe Somaly My
Mind's exploding every time I try
something new it's [ __ ] awesome
yeah dude if you go to I was in Rome
once and in like the charcuterie trays
boom it's like a standard there before
every meal in the restaurant it's just
you get a charcuterie and it's like it
was unfuckin real yeah unfuckin real you
see a little kid eating charcuterie
that's pretty [ __ ] classy I'll tell
you that yeah yeah yeah Italians doing
different I go on the road with virzi
and after if we go out to like wine bars
I don't get like you know 150 no
charcuterie boards I'm like give me give
me a PBR and a hooker let's go what do
we do there yeah virzi I've had a meal
or two adverse ii it's he's a good man
to eat with yeah he's a good man d he
with i what he got fully I got a
two-part question have you ever worn a
chain on the outside of your shirt when
that shirt was a mock turtleneck I think
so yeah yes yes that's going in the file
but I think it was an ankh like it was
almost like an African kind of vibe
what's a knock knock is an Egyptian
symbol okay and I think it was one of
those on like a leather it was a little
more like African medallion style
it wasn't like gaudy cheap trying yeah I
was talking I'm talking gold here no no
no never a gold gold Joe I never had a
gold chain I've had this silver chain
since I was a kid but I never wore Don
what's on it
Mary Blessed Mother I didn't thank you
for a religious guy I'm not my dad gave
it to me when I was young so it's just
about my dad giving it to me yeah those
are more about superstition anything I
got a few of those to that I would never
let go over throw out just because
you're like waiting for a [ __ ] bolt
the lightning the hitch if you did yeah
exactly I would have pegged you for a
gold chain guy no no my cousin was but
not me
most of your cousins will let cousins
there into the gold James yeah not me no
no um let's see
anyone in your family ever own a Snuggie
no okay anybody in your family ever own
a Flowbee yeah okay slipping slide now
we never had one
we at hole in ground yeah this is one of
the first in-ground pools we've had on
this show
welcome to you Follies above-ground
trash yeah not too bad did you have a
diving board in that pool Joe yeah yeah
and did you also here's the piece that
results did you have a slide no yes yeah
only [ __ ] like real real rich kids
whose dad owned like construction
companies had a slide that was on money
it was always right next to the diving
board to right that are right yeah now
in-ground pool diving board how deep was
the in-ground how far to go down eight
feet you have the white in the pool to
four nights women yeah Wow one question
could you change the color of the lights
yeah we had all the different holy [ __ ]
how much money do you have working here
right now
holy cow this guy is [ __ ] loaded the
light cover it was just covers it was
pieces of plastic that would have blown
my mind if I were to walk back there
what is that purple holy my parents did
not have a lot of money growing up but
my grandfather bought them that pool he
lived my grandfather got sick before he
died and he came and he lives with my
parents and his dying gift to them was
putting that pool in with his with the
money he had oh it's not [ __ ] I have
[ __ ] class act right there yeah then
you don't pay taxes on it either you
know what I mean his beak yeah exactly
but they couldn't never done that
without him did I was the 40 G's in cash
that's buried under the poor yeah
exactly I remember the first time I know
you won't you see the red pool dude I
thought I was the [ __ ] Playboy
Mansion I was
what the [ __ ] is this yeah the colored
lights they were amazing that was some
kid yeah it's like the Christmas thing
it's fun it's fine have you ever
followed a band around to multiple
cities and/or gone to the same concert
back to back like if a band comes into
town if you get on to the concert twice
that I've done a couple times very
selectively but no I wouldn't never
followed a band never followed fish or
anything like that
Dave Matthews Band Joe tell us now did
you go on tour with Dave Matthews never
even went to one show no were you a fan
of any local Philly bands down the shore
back in the day like mr. Greenjeans are
now the cover band
yeah all those [ __ ] dorks going to
like you know Avalon or something he
could go to see some [ __ ] cornball
sing and if you want to comb it baby
who was the big one in Jersey in Philly
they were the most popular cover band
they were the biggest bar band they had
our CD it was called live from the Stone
Pony
I thought it was mr. green that's the
mystery goodness there was one because I
worked at Rainbow records in Norristown
when I was in high school they actually
had the cover bands CD at the store yeah
maybe it was I I played in bands I hated
that cover band [ __ ] I [ __ ] hated it
yeah it really sucked yeah
was it the merry band no it might have
been mr. Greenjeans I don't remember are
you an Eagles fan just by default I'm
not a sports guy I never have been but
you know if I'm gonna root for a team it
would be the Eagles okay have you ever
joining answer I was excited when they
won the Super Bowl I knew what that
meant you know and all that stuff so to
an extent have you ever been to a
wedding at a VFW or a Knights of
Columbus I know you're Italian yeah
probably yeah
yeah something yeah yeah so it was it
have you ever been have you recently
been to one that's been a cash bar not
recently but I've definitely been to
them you've been to a wedding that was
in the cash bar yeah yeah that's I
didn't know if I miss something
he still gets on the bugles definitely
I've also been to weddings where they
only had beer and wine they didn't have
liquor also been to weddings where they
had to send the people out to get more
liquor cuz we exhausted the bar I've
been there yeah yes they always drove to
Delaware
run down to Delaware real quick yeah
have you ever been in a wedding when a
fight broke out yep have you ever worn a
leather jacket to a funeral to a no no I
just was thinking out of necessity if I
had to want it I was like visiting and
didn't have a suit with me and then
somebody died off sudden that's happened
to me where you're scrambling to find
you know but know anyone your family on
a pinball machine no but I own an arcade
machine ah that's pretty good yeah okay
your apartment in New York
yeah it's you can't see it it's back
there actually what is it start star
wars 1983 Los Angeles yeah I got it in
LA I barely got it we barely got it into
this apartment I don't know how the [ __ ]
I'm gonna get it out of here I actually
have anxiety when I think about it it
was so hard to get into this he's the
way that stairwells are but but you had
a transporter from Los Angeles to an
apartment in New York yeah I move I have
moved well I had all my [ __ ] you know
it's not too cheap right there that cost
you a pretty penny
mr. deucey is looking like something
that a big your other room a trampoline
yeah when was the last time you're at a
water park yeah I can Kyle hood okay
that childhood Bateen maybe 21 maybe
mm-hmm if they're going in your 30s
that's a tough look no I'm it's had no
it's been I can't even remember I just
have two more questions for you mr. De
Rosa have you ever been camping yeah
garbage garbage types of camping to
camper and tents camper who's who's
camper my uncle's pop-up now no but it
had an extension yeah sweet yeah and
then I did tent 110 camping tip yeah
okay my last one is have you ever worn a
no fear t-shirt now I was very against
that hall I hated no fear I hated geo
trackers I hated all that [ __ ] that all
went hand in hand I really hated that
whole thing are you guys remember the
absolute t-shirts it would be like
absolute whatever like yeah absolutely
yeah absolutely cross or something like
that absolute garbage of the people that
bought those things yeah yeah I I really
hated that whole that was when I was I
don't know if this is still a thing or
not but when I was in high school and
you know getting into like going on
trips to the beach with your buddies and
party culture or whatever that you get
into in high skin high school into
college that was all very much like frat
boy Ambercrombie and fetch [ __ ] yeah
like we we really we weren't into that
stuff you know it was a lot of the
beaded necklace crap you know the shell
necklaces the shell yeah all that [ __ ]
you know was
that's got one last question for you Joe
sure have you or any member of your
family ever been on a duck boat or a
double-decker bus tour members of my
family have been on bus tours but no not
me
have they ever gone to one of the tours
in Italy we like the vacation package
dude my mom was mr. Gowan one but
[ __ ] Kovac hit and she was Marilla
was she taking a protein shake in a
Perillo oh my god Kevin I wouldn't tell
any I'd cut this out that is [ __ ] know
why I want to send my parents on one of
those though that's true yeah that might
be well like it do it if you're thinking
about it these I mean you know my mom's
in her [ __ ] this you know who knows
sixties late 60s what's she gonna be
[ __ ] trekking around Rome with a
[ __ ] map and not yet she barely
speaks English but I'm on a boss and let
some [ __ ] idiot show them to six
things they need to see trying to buy
smokes at a Wawa yeah you've got a Wawa
[Laughter]
you have a go to Wawa order Joe yeah I
do actually I get on it I usually add
why do I get an Italian and a meatball
but but if it's if it's like the
holidays sometimes I'll get the turkey
thing and the gobbler yeah gentleman Joe
yeah yeah yeah sometimes a good but I
usually get to it'll Wawa a big on that
any scent like I got Shorty's the other
night in New York which is a great spot
for sandwiches I always get to I get an
Italian and a cheesesteak
I always it's it's way more enjoyable
smart move match the gentleman move
right there
ladies and gentlemen Joe DeRosa Joe
thank you much so much for sitting in
with this is there anything you want the
you want the gang out there to know
anything coming up
well Kareem Fisher and I have a podcast
it's on gas digital it's called without
a country
we cover the news by taking four stories
each week and covering reading the far
left and far right takes on each story
and then trying to find some gray area
in the middle of the two so a lot of fun
and I enjoy doing it and it's it's doing
well and we want it to keep doing well
and keep growing so please go listen to
it wherever you get your podcasts and if
you want to get it from gasps digital W
code w AC gets you free 30-days over
there awesome okay you so much Kippy you
got anything for him now just make sure
you rate review subscribe on iTunes full
video available on YouTube and check out
that [ __ ] patreon everybody yessir
guys thank you so much to listen I'll be
back next week with a brand new episode
of are you garbage ladies and gentlemen
one more time mr. Joe DeRosa Joe thank
you buddy
thanks man yeah thanks guys I'd save